everyone its Warren and today we have
the first teaser trailer for Wonder
Woman 1984 now we're supposed to get the
teaser trailer tomorrow so this is like
a teaser teaser trailer or they're
releasing the full trailer tomorrow but
anyways let's go right into the first
teaser trailer the first footage that
we've seen for Wonder Woman 1984 needs
you nothing good is born from life and
greatness is not what you think
[Music]
so hey everyone I'm GOG adults I'm here
to let you all know that something very
exciting is coming your way this Sunday
December 8 you can get in on the action
before anyone else by commenting below
with a photo of your fiercest Wonder
Woman pose then tune in right here to
watch it all unfold see you Sunday
mm-hmm so tomorrow so tomorrow is the
official panel at CC xB I guess they
just teased this today this was on
Twitter possibly Instagram I didn't
check this is on Twitter so just a
little teaser it's funny because it
seemed like they cut off a few people's
faces and like cut them off from the
side I think that's obviously going to
be Steve Trevor I think a lot of people
don't know that he's going to come back
because he died in the last movie so
we'll see about that but I'm super
excited for tomorrow tomorrow of course
I'll do a reaction to the full trailer
and I'll do a breakdown to the full
trailer but it looked like she was last
sowing on to lightning at the end and of
course she has a God and that could be
Zeus so he could be making an appearance
in the next one so that was that was
pretty cool and I'm and I'm gonna say
that the person getting cut off even the
guy on the gun with Steve Trevor
so we will see tomorrow as always thank
you all so much for watching
well fluff